after seizing power in afghanistan the
taliban are now looking to form a
government
the challenges that they face are
immense the economy is on the brink of
collapse and the united nations is
warning of an imminent food crisis many
people are trying to leave the country
and those who remain they face an
uncertain future
the wards are busy at wazir muhammad
akbar khan hospital
the facility is just down the road from
kabul airport
it treated many victims of last week's
attacks there which killed at least 170
people
many of the nursing staff here are women
after the taliban took power they were
afraid they would lose their jobs
when the situation first occurred it was
very difficult for us we were worried
about what would happen
but thankfully
there have been no problems regarding
our work
when the taliban took over we stayed
home for just one day
after that the management contacted us
and told us to get back to our duties
without any fear or apprehension we came
back and resumed our work
in kandahar the taliban have put on a
show of military equipment left behind
by the americans
a kind of victory parade lines of
humvees with taliban
a fighters hawk helicopter flying low
over crowds
but the islamists will now need to set
about ruling the country
the lines outside banks back in kabul
are a hint at the rapidly declining
economic situation
that and the soaring prices in the
bazaars
markets are not as crowded as they were
during the republic government and
people are staying in their homes in
fear
business is not so good
in the day since the rule of the taliban
arrived we've actually had no government
we're waiting to see what will happen
what could happen first is more fighting
the taliban's military victory in
afghanistan was swift and overwhelming
but it isn't complete these militias
from the panchi region north of kabul
have not succumbed and they're vowing to
resist
[Applause]
should be reconciled with the taliban
they should put their weapons down
war occupation force were never a
solution for this country and never will
be
if they want to enter panshi with force
that's a pipe dream they will take to
their grave
the taliban never succeeded in capturing
panchayat the last time they held power
their massing forces in an attempt to
take it this time
the region was the gateway used by the
us when it overthrew the taliban 20
years ago
it's a weak spot they can't ignore now
all right for more now i'm joined by
journalist franz marty he's in kabul for
us good evening to you france what are
we hearing about these fighters in the
pangaea region are they going to be able
to hold their own against the taliban
that's difficult to say there has been
since yesterday again renewed fighting
of these taliban forces
uh that amassed around uh panchi it is
hard to verify how the situation exactly
looks like uh because these telephone
networks are sometimes down
i couldn't reach anyone in the punch
here tonight
there have been reports that the taliban
managed to get on the pulses
from uh from bahrain on the process that
like lead to punch here and what is the
big difference to like last time when
pancho held out last time they had uh
all syria's northeast that were not
olive on controlled um supply lines this
time they're
completely surrounded by
taliban however the terror and
the traditional uh like resistance of
the people in panchayat
will make it a hard fight for the
taliban and there are reports that the
taliban is already moving to establish
um a government they could name their
name their supreme authority as early as
tomorrow
but that could be the easy part right do
they do they have people there who can
govern who are qualified to help provide
the basic services for the 40 million
people in afghanistan
what is the most likely outcome and what
the taliban have to some extent already
like tried is this that they invite
um former government workers to resume
their services former civil servants the
talibans seem to be aware that their own
fighters um they lack certain skills
they can't run like services in the
whole government for example in your
report we have seen in the hospital the
taliban have kept the minister of health
of public health
uh from the former government and asked
him to continue his service
they also ask like other
civil servants to do the same so what
they are trying to do is to co-opt
these people who have the necessary
skills
and of course the world looking at
afghanistan today now with u.s military
gone
what are you seeing in the capital kabul
out on the streets are you seeing as
many women and girls in public spaces as
you would have seen let's say six months
ago
i was today on the street uh scenes were
pretty normal but there are remarkably
fewer women and girls on the street
doesn't mean that there are none and it
should also be noted that so far the
taliban haven't banned women to the
house as they have done like during
their first regime so far it is that
like women are wary to go out because
they don't know what might happen
this is of course a huge problem
but yeah how this will exactly play out
and what will exactly be announced
remains still to be seen
okay friends marty with the latest
tonight from kabul france as always
thank you
and joining me now is mariam safi
executive director of the organization
for policy research and development
studies it's a pro-democracy think tank
in kabul she now works from toronto
canada it's good to have you on the
program the the taliban they say that
they will soon present a new afghan
government and they promise that it will
be inclusive
what what does that mean to you
well i think um at the present time we
don't have a clear definition from the
taliban as to what they think inclusive
is
for afghans
inclusivity uh inclusive government is
one that would take into consideration
the multi-faceted aspect of afghan
society a government that respects the
rights of women youth minorities and
other vulnerable groups in our society
and third an inclusive government would
be one that would be willing to discuss
with its people the type of governance
structure that should come about but
what we're seeing now is that the
taliban are saying that they're going to
be announcing a new government very
shortly and uh that the leader of the of
the state will be their amiro nominee or
the commander of the faithful uh and uh
and it will appoint a president or prime
minister uh thereafter to run the
country so from the structure that we're
seeing right now uh it uh it does not
seem inclusive so that's why there's a
question how are they defining the term
inclusivity because it's certainly not
how the people of afghanistan have to
find inclusivity but do you think it's
even conceivable that a a woman can
become a minister in a taliban run
government would a woman even want
to have that job
well just today i read that taliban
officials have stated that a woman
cannot be a minister and that a woman
who has worked with the with the united
states cannot work in the government
um so that's what i've heard as of today
and so no
it seems they cannot and in the past uh
in previous meetings uh they have had
stated that a woman cannot become a
president that a woman cannot become a
judge but now as the days are going on
you're starting to see more and more of
those barriers and and how they the
obscurity around what they meant in
terms of women's rights per sharia is
now slowly coming to light yeah and it's
the realities of this taliban that you
are talking about there that has
countries around the world you know
reluctant asking whether or not they
should recognize that this taliban
government i want you to take a listen
to what the german foreign minister had
to say about that today
i personally believe there is no getting
away from engaging in talks with the
taliban
on the one hand because we have to find
solutions to problems like the continued
operation of kabul airport
secondly because we simply cannot afford
any instability in afghanistan
that would encourage terrorism and also
have a massive impact on neighbouring
countries
let me ask you
do you agree with that um recognizing
the the taliban rule establishing
diplomatic relationships is that really
the only way
forward the only way to prevent the
taliban from once again
being terrorists
the international community had long
told the people of afghanistan
and many of these meetings i have been
in and we've had these discussions where
they've said that we will always retain
our leverage on the taliban to ensure
that when they are developing their
government and when they are running the
country if and when that were to take
place that is of course that that these
leverages would allow us to make sure
that that they
they remain committed to their promises
of protecting citizens and their
properties ensuring that there are no
prosecutions of former government
employees ngos journalists and others
and respecting women's rights and more
importantly bringing about an inclusive
government
now i think that that needs to be
maintained i think what the
international community needs to do now
is to hit a balance where on the one
hand the country is undergoing and it
will continue to undergo a massive
humanitarian crisis so they have to be
able to get aid onto the ground to be
able to address that while on the other
hand they have to maintain pressure on
the taliban to ensure that their own com
commitments and promises that they've
been making to the people of afghanistan
are respected otherwise the people of
afghanistan truly have no one to hold
faith upon well the economy of
afghanistan 80 of that economy is
reliant on foreign aid of some sort
that's why u.s president biden says that
the west still has enormous economic
leverage over the taliban so how should
that leverage be used moving forward
like as i mentioned earlier the taliban
have made commitments they made these
commitments as early as when they
entered kabul that they're going to
respect inclusivity they're going to
respect the rights of citizens and
minorities and that they're going to
bring stability they also said that this
is now going to be a test for them to
prove to the people of afghanistan that
they will bring that peace that they've
long awaited for now those commitments
they have to be held on and to hold them
upon those commitments you have to have
leverage and so the international
community should not let go of those
leverage engaging is very important
continuing to engage with the taliban i
agree with the foreign minister of
germany is important but
throwing in all all that they have to be
able to maintain that pressure would be
catastrophic
with the organization for policy
research and development studies we
appreciate your time and your insights
tonight thank you
the end of an era in afghanistan and the
start of an uncertain future as well
let's discuss that with naheed farid she
was a member of the parliament in
afghanistan she chaired the house
women's affairs commission and she
serves on the advisory board of the
afghanistan u.s democratic peace and
prosperity council good to have you with
us on dw
first i want to ask are you disappointed
by president biden's words
uh hello and thank you for having me uh
unfortunately these awards disappointed
the whole nation of afghanistan you know
it took 20 years and millions of and
billions of dollars to take afghanistan
back from taliban and giving them giving
afghanistan back to taliban
and you know when we think and we see
that
we have um
the whole
the whole 20 years of efforts and
blood and treasure and
and the sacrifice for nothing
you can understand how the
is feeling about that you know the
afghanistan security situation was not a
secret to president biden was not a
secret to the world was not a secret to
intelligence community this information
was publicly available in major outlets
that that afghanistan situation is not
ready for redraw is not ready
um for abandoning and imagine what the
people of afghanistan are thinking what
afghan national security forces us are
feeling these these days that the ward
abandoned them the united states united
nations
the european union the nato allies all
of them just just decided to leave this
country in hand of taliban and taliban
is the same brutal group that have the
same brutal system and
suppressing the people of afghanistan is
especially women so i i just i just if i
could jump in there i just i'd like to
ask because you know president biden has
said the u.s is still going to use its
economic leverage uh to negotiate with
the taliban do you think the u.s and its
allies as well you mentioned the
european union still have credibility in
afghanistan
actually
no one is listening to the people of
afghanistan and asking about the
credibility of of the world
in their public perception but the
reality is that as we speak right now
the various production of taliban are
competing for poverty new government
they are locked out of the international
banking system they have
no or little cash in hand they
the most importantly they do not have
international recognition and this is
the time this is the time for the world
for the united states for you and for
germany for ipu for g7 g20 all this this
this
um
um platforms to show a strength in the
face of the regime
uh that most african reject that most
afghan fear that most afghans want to
leave the country because of this regime
afghans should be able to decide the
future of their own country for
themselves without any then we have to
we have to understand this they want to
have close relations with with your
nation with the us nation with the old
world with your regional partners and
and we need that kind of government we
need we don't know we don't need a
government that is forced
to to to rule the country miss ferry if
i can jump in there you know the taliban
has said the taliban have said that they
they want to create now an inclusive
government that women could also be part
of this government what do you think of
that do you believe that
taliban don't do what they say
okay they just beg for the the
legitimacy of the war of the world
including united states but i lost count
of how many death threats i received
how many deaths threats my colleagues in
the parliament received
they assassinated so many of the friends
colleagues who were activists were
journalists
who were government officials they
continued searching houses they
continued
behaving people in the public if you
think the situation in afghanistan is
bad now
and the word do not act quickly
if you
give the team the opportunity to
consider
a power
without any oversight without an
intervention of united nation of united
states of eu of germany the world will
witness a regime of brutality a regime
of terror
which we have not seen before because
they they have a lot of equipment
they have so many things in their hands
and then
they can act much more brutal than
before miss farid uh just one more quick
question from me given that situation
that you just depicted for us what is
your hope for the future of the country
you know as we are speaking there is
this resistance against taliban
in northern afghanistan
as president biden continues to say that
afghans are not willing
to defend their values there are
resistance in the country that is
against the the
taliban regime and they have allies
among all all
tribes groups from all over the country
and even outside the country and that's
my hope
the 30 million of afghans
50 millions of women 70 percent of
afghans who are youth they are my hope
we don't abandon our country like others
did and we will continue to fight for
the values and freedom of afghan people
we have to leave it there naheed farid
member of the afghanistan parliament
joining us thank you so much
you